hello everyone welcome to today's
broadcast preventive strategies in
emerging mental disorders in young
people clinical staging and
translational research in Judea Rourke
of lab roots today's educational web
seminars presented by lab routes leading
scientific social networking website and
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning we have a few important
announcements before we begin due to
scheduling and travel conflicts of the
speaker dr. Patrick McGorry we have
pre-recorded his presentation for this
reason we will not host a live Q&A
following dr. Majoris presentation you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window if you
have any technical problems viewing or
sharing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or submit
your problem through the green Q&A
button lower left this is an educational
webinar and that's offers free
continuing education credits after the
webinar is over please click on the CD
button located in the bottom left hand
corner of your web page and follow the
process of obtaining your credits I
would now like introduce today's speaker
dr. Patrick Liguori dr. McGorry is the
executive director of origin professor
of youth Mental Health at the University
of Melbourne and a director of the board
of the national youth Mental Health
Foundation is a world leading researcher
in the area of early psychosis and youth
mental health and that's strong
interested in promoting mental health of
the homeless refugees and asylum seekers
dr. McCoy his work has played a critical
role in the development of safe
effective treatments and innovative
research into the needs of young people
with emerging mental disorders notably
psychotic and severe mood disorders he
has also played a major part in the
transformational reform of mental health
services to better serve the needs of
vulnerable young people dr. migori has
published extensively in the specialists
literature and serves as editor-in-chief
of early intervention and psychiatry
he's a fellow the Academy of the Social
Sciences in Australia and is the current
president of the Society for mental
health research and the president-elect
of the schizophrenia international
research society please refer to dr.
McCoy's image in the topless
corner of your screen for more
information about him I will now turn it
over to dr. migori for his presentation
you
okay and well welcome everybody my name
is Patrick Midori I'm the professor of
youth Mental Health at University of
Melbourne and the executive director of
origin the national center of excellence
is mental health and today I'm going to
be talking about how we can with
existing knowledge transform mental
health care and medical outcomes
specifically young people with emerging
mental disorders using some treatments
and some key concepts and kind of
staging a very simple idea early early
intervention and focus on young people
because 75% of major mental disorders
are made before the end in 25 now matter
help it's been the poor cousin in so
many ways and mental health care and
advanced research and medical research
but we think it's awakening giant and
this is a cutter from major newspaper in
lovin from the year or so ago and the
contextual election campaign and the
health care mental health has to be the
awakening giant and I'll explain lights
this is where worldwide planners great
interest in global mental health
especially developing countries where
it's a very more related issue than his
rich countries if you're saying
something and and the economist's are
becoming a new best friend because the
World Economic Forum among many other
publications and cooking leap
interesting articles in The Economist
magazine really gonna call showed the
four sets of economic analyses in 2011
sentence mental illness is a bigger
threat to equal and output the gdp over
the next 20 years and in developed and
developing countries it's kind of
important economically as cancer where
that sums of money according to the
treatment will show top and it's on the
higher and probably a little bit more
important in cardiovascular disease so
of the line commune with the readers
mental illness is the major issue
and it's being neglected compared to the
ugly diving areas the public notice some
Australian going back happily is now
bottom then surveys are done little
illness and local health major issues in
the public mind now which was not the
case going back some years so public
through self-interest and as far as a
greater awareness understanding at least
some metal into strictly depression
anxiety and they realize that some
severe necks on the line here if we
don't actually do a better job and you
need to give the public a much stronger
voice here and once the time of get a
voice when the park politicians were
actually sued for any line our public
broadcaster and the major broadcaster in
Australia the ABC showing broadcasting
commission basically divides a whole
week of programming to tube mental
illness each year now that two years at
least and it's radio TV internet
everything you cannot avoid McAllister
II won't we can arch over in Australia
so these are all positive elements so it
means leaders to tackle some key issues
which we're in the field of psychiatry
and love this family and how do we
actually develop a blog Gnostic
approached is going to be useful
obviously validity is important issue
here but and we front tackle the
liabilities via them another position
that song that problematical point but
attend we have really look at how to
value diagnosis remember and allow to
add value that's the whole project
labeling people in this way I mean
Logan's about going but the river it is
a purpose line utility to it's a
worthwhile thing to do um seem like a
lot of controversy and criticism
including two people and I think
intriguing than a problem
not like after Frances fear deep long as
this is wrong sharing different for
widening your diagnostic boundaries as
he season and now he's in a rearguard
action to win back the boundaries of the
prospects the problem here is that this
is where you would be very difficult to
develop early intervention if this is a
specific console anxiety is there about
what normal is wrong and the written
down a variety of theirs because of the
crude and poor quality tripled the
people are provided with by a lumbering
of unresolved and taught low morale
medical systems and I think if we have a
sip rise and cheerfully balance is
proportional treatment response with
safety as a priority and respected
analysis of the key issue then it would
be a problem with intervening early in
people who are on that the border of
just normal life troubles and emerging
liberal disorder it's very difficult
odiferous previous events across at the
only girl in Vegas something a lot of
computer guidance going on dear which
fee into people's prejudices when
anxiety and positional anti psychiatrist
or more sense a bit of a little bit more
detail normal people actually aren't
excluded from the whole system that
example being pregnant women and
especially time is pregnancy others
welcome our people who don't actually
have an illness but I've got risk
factors for speeding allowed to see the
doctor and have preventive health care
for cardiovascular disease cancer risk
diabetes it's different it's in fact its
value this month not world against
exactly value so this is a real
disconnect between the way we approach
psychiatry when we're warning people to
avoid care because you might be normal
and the opposite stance was taken me in
one general health care I forgot about
this but we're actually time why is this
why is the
double stand a lot of difference between
mental illness physical risks or alluded
to already we have come for a long way
back into poetry and has been and then
call treatments powerful treatment and
then particularly in the u.s. i will say
over treatment because treatment in the
u.s. is equated with drug therapy [ __ ]
logic on social forms of written a lot
respected funded to the extent they
should be and so you know there's an
x-ray value if it is diagnosis or
acceptance of the need for care is made
that but that will mean brought their
view there's everyone knows that not
everyone with poor mental health needs
drug therapy and a stepwise approach
based on risk and safety is is onto the
way to go but then obviously speaking
and labeling and discrimination these
issues come into it another issues the
soft bigotry of low expectations where
people are not really expected to to
fully recover and so you know i mean
that in a bit of a disincentive to
actually see the hog we might win get up
time offering cure when i'm offering
hope in sufficient quantities and we
don't expect people and their respective
and a resilience and down could benefit
from comprehensive treatment so that
someone is really better change you
experience in schizophrenia and that
much more optimistic approach to switch
tre now linked to a dimension and more
intensive treatment or merely stage of
illness and we are seeing my very
reserved swear that's clearly properly
so i think the harmful cultures the the
Calot and narrow forms of treatment and
the the formative big lot of experience
when they encounter traditional
psychiatric care as a rugged trusted
companies and undermine this idea that
we should be productive and seek people
so hopefully will seek help in the early
stages illness
other treatment isn't the magic problem
in which countries this is a report to
the OECD from 2014 where they say the
current week's state of negative carrier
unacceptable this isn't rich countries
imagine what's happening in the
developing world so more must be done to
make methanol count and improve the
larger by suffering temecula well it
must be given the importance it demands
by policymakers attention resources and
parsley prior paralyze our evaluation
now leader motherhood statements and
their advocacy stagnancy platform it's
really a political issue for the public
to consider everywhere in the world
we've seen the connector the mcneil
whether it's um in what world countries
with homelessness and mental illness or
even worse scenarios in developing
countries the general experience of
planes is too little too late and it's
very hard to access high-quality care it
is possible but even where there are
significant numbers a little more
professionals probably cannot be assured
because of the culture and systemic
issues and also try issues so it's not
surprisingly polemics have made another
one The Book of World by am very good
good and basically it's like petrol on
the farm it is n controversy on through
the defense system hasn't worked as well
as it is hope and there are reasons for
this first time it's a it's kind of our
catalyst for all the ambivalence that is
felt more exam the clueless in general
and implementing the toxic shock after
care than are available conscience so a
new way here that diagnosis mystery and
and gentleness and I try to outline some
of the issues in injury and the lamp it
in 2013 about notice one is it for
what's the purpose of it
and we came down on the side our utility
dark notices need to be for treatment
selection some people think it's
important as a prognostic guide which
you practice i would say for secondary
further diagnose the main purpose is to
to extinguish the treat of them asian
taken a should be so guys i just cannot
do that in the reporting they did
diagnostic reforms being under way in
the US during research the main criteria
which is really for research diagnose
easel to try to progress and
understanding of my discovery terms but
not very much used to clinicians
misinformation approach that's being
developed here at least not on the short
short term i wrote it makes a lot of
tension in those aren't wave and a
crunch which we've been developing for
the last 10 years in australia and
exporting anything and collaborating
another fantasy to another part of the
world with clinical staging work if as
many other features on the are dark
approach in the sense that it some time
to be trained staff roster can change
the traditional categories but it's also
better than categorical structure to it
so that down the road if you stay in
illness as well as different control
part wavy patterns and then category
important Commission because and the
categories a yes or no decision about
whether estate one or two let's say
might very much influenced the target
people it's selected with safety and
effectiveness all those treatments and
we punish them a federal court number
Pegasus 2006 and fifth down right about
this it's a huge the guardian just some
more papers here it's from being adopted
within different styles already like
schizophrenia by coming through and
bipolar sort of them using biomarker
research and
then just think about show you now and
what it is quite a single thing develop
them usually in oncology and other areas
of Medicine like the psychology of
subtyping strategy to help select safe
and effective treatments and predict
outcome as well some more refined
negative diagnosis so knowing that
someone has breast cancer is
insufficient to know how to go about
treating them stage and even profiling
the patient these things there are
additional things that need to be done
to refine the diagnosis but savings
certainly continue to do that probably
going to be useful in early intervention
because it's trying to identify the
earliest stage and I'm need for care
there's risk of fearfulness prisons and
early symptoms present or area sign but
it also protects against overtreatment
online and 32 before which shall mean it
is a genuine issue and then so this
benefit the shooting and ratio it is
very important to consider and it
changes from stage to stage stage feel
whole breast cancer will receive
intensive treatment which we will have
much more serious side effects
potentially in the distant attempt to
achieve you know better a better outcome
but the outcome is that overall compared
to stage one and the treatment treatment
is certainly more risky the other thing
is staging dues hopefully clarify the
confusing and ray of biological research
findings which have been found in
psychiatry crossing the different
syndromes was more continuity across
symptoms improve differentiation and
staging might help to actually clarify
the significance of a particular by
market as to whether they are markers
and disease whether they call the
respect which you smart as a respective
what their significance actually is okay
so problem is that some some researchers
have taken up the staging idea really in
their own
tyler and research for schizophrenia or
bipolar or another one and try to
develop it in parallel relation but
actually stages of trance diagnosing
idea and we do think with the early
stages of illness at least at that point
near in class around the early stage one
pass the places are quite full potential
and there it would be a range of robin
outcome is from these early stage or
some fictional conditions and perhaps
mixtures of comorbidity other time as
well which makes it even more complex so
it's a multi lead situation and i think
that another idea that geo a loss is
written about is the idea that symptoms
might might actually influence each
other and mine actually increase the
risk of other symptoms developing so
it's kind of a very dynamic situation
that you see in these young patients as
they experience the early stages the
early riches on arrival in disorder of
course the fungus can resolve and remit
without progressing as well so it's not
a deterministic or an excellent project
like we often see in cancer for example
it's a much more dynamic seeing cracks
fork into the spirit of diseases like
asthma cos alpha where alpha do come and
go and the bong building like the main
staging can be useful in terms of
practice and shame trust and colleagues
insignia Sherman transition across any
stage to the next stage results not
working out come unless of course
freakin changes if the trigger is
changed by pollution and plays another
stage change which is what's meant to
happen for example if someone goes for
substrate onto psychosis to sustain food
pressure and psychosis in antipsychotics
our standard at that point and the
patient and typically responds very well
so that sets a better outcome actually
despite these increases stage
as we started to look at the world
literature on this across diagnostic
groups but it's difficult to find enough
information in many respects because the
only standings have not been researched
and efficiently wildly particularly when
beyond psychosis and so a lot more work
can be done to actually fill out this
picture and this is why we you pretend
to mystic force taking so I think this
is lamb this slide here is meant to just
show that different biomarkers and be
studied strongly by stage and they might
make more strongly to state in fact then
to particular syndrome although a little
bit of electrics and these beads are
biomarkers obviously a mental potential
therapeutic making such as well which
which will allow us to test the religion
Asian Studies and then again staking
important framework for computer
designed in that kind of information and
follow-up series it just runs at Alabama
which is cross diagnostic hippocampal
volume loss is seeming depression PTSD
and schizophrenia and we can see here
that if I kosis free and world it's
family it means to example with the plan
develops with worsening or chord
progression of the illness is a more
chronic forms so it's more like that and
Marco progression and it's truly the
rich soon probably love that when I'm
still valid it's some some there were
things we have to go to decisions of the
elected same ok excuse those two so just
look at all get more quickly and a very
early dimension it in psychosis it's a
possibility EDM space prototype for
earlier dimension more broadly in the
field and the we try to young student
life cross diagnostic approaches here
could go to the general intervention in
sikar
and of course despite of the imperative
and the rhetoric about seeking elderly
and muddy elimination often the reality
is some of difference those are the
slides and suggests yet in 20 years
we've met a lot of progress the name
frontier and this has been the
programmer or cleveland high risk or
under horrific state the first stage of
little help allowing psychosis pathway
at which a need for care is clearly
present and also a risk for progression
to more serious forms of psychosis also
credit and this was captured by an
operational country reality using our
developer merely lighting nineties in
melbourne and they basically capture a
substrate stretch on psychotic state and
also bring in family history and other
amongst asleep runs in terms of change
and deteriorating as well but
essentially it's a sub threshold risk
stage for psychosis now what I have a
need for care in itself is not just a
fanatic risk states such as someone who
turns up for a random blood she learns
found out now when blood sugar but have
no symptoms but if that lead to diabetes
this is quite different these patients
are actually distressed help-seeking
functionally appeared with plunder
assessment functioning gas cause in in
in the low 50s and really quite
struggling with it and the transition to
adulthood with their relationships with
identity formation with academic
performance or work performance so they
have a need for can and latterly no
doubt about themselves with leather
artists from Tyler foods or pony shows
the riskless i hope that i previously
percent it might be less demand more we
can converse but it's sort of a very
substantial risk of persistent psychotic
universe now you might say that
these patients are false positives
because most people do not develop
recycle your people learn sesli the
focus of these criteria trying to
predict that so that's true but in fact
if we funnel applications who do not
transitions the vast majority of them
all of all apart from seven percent and
some form of them mental health or
mental illness particularly you need
names iety often complicated by
personality and substance use issues and
these patients have very significant
need for like us immediately Megan
healthcare but mental health care over a
significant period of time even if they
don't transition psychosis me and then
we do not transition also have
persistent or fluctuating subjects also
countries which caused districts and and
repaired as well so there's no question
and that these patients have a valid
right to entry to medical care and the
scare mongering that went on about that
let's and led to be exclusive with
lovely category from dsm is certainly
not justified probably probably not to
put it in dsm-5 because of a broader
trans diagnostic challenge here which
one been created by despots who else are
conscious but the idea that somehow the
misinformation of these patients being
model or a phonetic is clearly has been
under service we need to provide care to
educators if you look at the rest of
medicine even a symptomatic patients at
risk as I submitted before like read our
babies besides it came to send only
chance of transition to diabetes are
offered psychosocial lifestyle change
and medication if they needed as now
they're still there so that's a
different standard no controversy there
and the same extent wear a 7.5
persistence rate risk of our major
cardiovascular and ranges within 10
years not luxury is for 10 years
proficient
ground to respect for these patients
again much less heat and in this in this
debate about there and what we've seen
for patients to learn this group 250
psychosis own already have a need for
care there's been a number of trial
carried out in these high-risk patients
over the years we conducted about four
in ourselves and other work into other
countries exactly the rest and overall
the neck analysis by right of entry card
shows that and the fifty percent risk
reduction in the first 12 months to
these treatments we have been offering
his trial and the good news is that
safer treatments like cbt and for
comment on the behavior of case
management are effective in reducing its
risk ever allow those antipsychotics and
fish oils but um the size of treatments
faculdade they work intention to maine
at least beyoncé's and that's sufficient
grounds for them to be honest firstly i
like to baby the same antipsychotics
should not be used as first-line
treatment now that's difficult in
quickly milk American where and usually
with the prescription pad happens much
more quickly because avail mindset and
also has financing systems there which
don't support psychosocial care that is
quite clear that medication should not
be used as first-line areas patients and
they should be provided with support cbt
and needs of a stripper for any other
issues that was ending with we've been
trying to replicate the raid exciting
fighters on the omega-3 fatty acids and
legumes be a lobotomy are we from
short-term and long-term benefits the
patients and now we're approaching
reporting liat lose result they don't
look at encouraging of the first study
and it may just prove to be a subgroup
that respond looks like omega-3 should
be his response
to somewhere between private area we can
identify clear the fence either the need
for care which and the substantial risk
of transitions or psychosis probably
somewhere between the twenty and forty
percent range we can induce this risk to
the provision of relatively specialized
psychosocial care it was like cbt there
are other comorbid on learning needs and
serums which means there's a valence for
other excessive and not just psychosis
and a range of outcomes we truly
persistent or recurrent of the
sub-threshold cycle psychotic symptoms
can occur you know commonly occur we
need to clarify the sequence of optimal
treatment for the entire disc stage and
societal another new study without to
start and I did it it needs to be done a
paranormal the position and tribute of
other syndromes that we don't continue
to research patients within these and
restrictive categories at the terror
over a century old and actually don't
work that relatively fairly stable
illness so need file funded by NIH is to
clarify the sequence of treatments
starting a very simple psychosocial
interventions testing or intensive ones
of a staff and then a BF fri-mon ran the
bases later on because this one end of
the SSRI prevented in terms of
transition psycho system perhaps your
protective and medications of course to
my depression but this is not why the
venue testing is trial it would be other
options that could be kid to tears i
presented for the opportunity but that's
not part of the current study omega-3
and logo thing is I clinics are open on
a choice after many months of the
patient actually not many response to
the series of sips a clear dimensions so
beyond the program or the alcoholic safe
and expertise test episode of psychosis
a bigger of the program in their
spherical epic back in like 92
which had a comprehensive early
detection strategy of the UNIX a team
our program goes into that the pace
clinic we had in patient care we had a
whole range of psychosocial and case
management options for pages over 50
years will looks including a number of
research orientated psychosocial
interventions such as cbt suicide
probation and adaptation blanket
vocational interventions based on the
IPS model around into so3 comprehensive
and in our experience and also in our
thirties conducted europe this target
model definitely proves that would be
the only outcome for patients in the
first two years and it saves money as
well this became a world like phenom
room during the nineteen ninety two
thousand see the artwork especially the
psychosis association bringing people
together and its focus the medicines
grown dramatically over the last two
decades of the 10th international ed of
this organization will be held in the
land it up later this year and it's
broadening focus in this conference to
me disorders and other making facilities
for education so I think psychosis has
been the template at the private time
but now we love me in researchers from
other domains to apply these ideas
across the board a letter very exciting
development these articles programs do
work in recess systematic review by the
enemy or natok published in quarantine a
year ago and even more valued folder
which chef you all this uncertainty
treatment and same to work and according
to this analysis and the more intensive
or watch the what you'd better
especially I used for another period of
time two years is probably too short
maybe it may patiently at least five
years intuitively sustained recoveries
it's cost effective and enjoyable
sparing the bottom quadrant here cheaper
and better so the abuse of
hospitalization it reduces the amount of
outpatient care 32 after some time as
well so and that comes later costs us
money why Arnold government's doing this
well many many more are in the US as a
result of the great study and coverage
last year we've seen 29 states we
understand study investment strongly in
irritation programs the UK is probably
the main leader of listing and to
thousands with massive increase in an
intervention teams across the whole of
England and emission raised well this is
it took a while to happen but um I
varsity was conducted in the US and
plunder my entire nation and it showed
positive outcomes for the more
specialized form of care for secure
patients and both until your symptoms
and functioning and it was particularly
the case see if I can find the right
side here yes if patients had a shorter
dup and this is kind of liberal you
liberally defined yeah because I'm
cynical mixers and with the division
point and patients attending had a
better response to these volunteers
moment in our failure and it's changed
in response a Brasilia so take that very
respected to treat it if you get in the
first few weeks and becoming psychotic
and those time extremely well and under
item division you transact about but
only up to about a year after that and
these 150 programs probably worth less
well they talk about what it's all over
that they're the patches son won't be
able to help because we do a lot more
psycho social damage and memorized by
then they're from Canada and ongoing
work in canada and denmark 50 please let
bagon eyes way and get so far that five
years of treatment
is only able to maintain the benefits of
these are intensive programs better than
two years so an extra softly against
need and it's time to care for a bit
longer at least amount of the some
patients might not need more intensive
treatment for a very long time but that
is very much the minority action so I
won't go through business under all the
program fee because its own psychosis
the outcomes actually purpose kids of
schizophrenia and cell phones when
people think except for functional
outcomes the fifth matting outcomes
tension cruel under time functional
outcomes are poor and less transform now
comes up supporting the practical
programs from location recovery and
looking after patients are much more
holistic intensive ways physical
counselor in the emerging problems is a
big killer for these patients a parallel
sides to your time and it's in a
preventive opportunity to actually help
these patients have healthy lives and
the voyage kind of vascular disease
other other whispers I might be exposed
to is a major priority so if we learn
some lessons in cancer here we try to in
cancer prisons and actually increasing
due to increasing writing speakers we've
got the successive treatment is because
it is included too and that's because
they prevent shin where they can they
certainly prioritize early diagnosis and
they get it right in terms of you know
most of the time between the balances of
bar risks and benefits and they don't
keep the patients out of care one study
patched up after attitude inside after
an initial episode of care they
sustained troopers and they follow up
patient so i give them students and
intensively as they needed for as long
as they needed and and that isn't
something we do not do in the health
care anywhere in the world lasting and
of course you never have got some
breakthrough vacations and centralizing
made a few care to mention that i can
and these are important
future benefits and there or we having
effect but they're not the reasons for
the downturn for the improvement in in
in our cousin cancer really the three
strange i mentioned earlier prevention
early diagnosis for st. regular being
the major contributors so far in my
opinion now just the last panel talk in
sponsoring on an extending our
intervention of a legend before beyond
psychosis into new territory new bottles
of care or crime need continued care and
we service journal ten years ago to
promote this idea across the diagnostic
spectrum and because one of the key
facts we have to understand is what
mental illnesses other chronic diseases
video from potentially product we look
at the incident curve with britain's
disease across the lifespan it's quite
different in little lists for my little
physical illness feel illness and they
didn't occur over 50 this is a cluster
of garden any creepy little child as you
can see two but between puberty and
middle age but especially between
puberty and mid twenties young people
are actually very physically healthy
these days in developed countries the
main scourge of the past line interface
diseases like TB tuberculosis I'm not
any Aeneas comment and the main health
problem actually mental ill health and
substance use disorders which surged
through adolescence p here nearly 20 of
them exist being or dropping off after
mid twenties so this is just but we
should have a very strong system of care
it's very very engaging young people
across the period of transition join our
lives and puberty 2020 which one is
pretty much when people become mature
NRC is a even a legally the ages 18 and
education at a change of 80 young people
not mature adult until university that
brains a lot mature would stop changing
to a little a 20 so and socially and
all those things where in flux to around
that time and that is reflected also in
this illness so we need a very big
understanding of this transitional
process of becoming as well and they
need to be much more responsive because
the rights of care wretched need for
care are very high 50 extender heaters
are figurative us study lead singer
figures in the southern hemisphere fifty
sixty percent of young people have a
need for care during this transitional
period at some point that doesn't mean
they all need long-term intensive
psychiatric treatment but probably more
than half of them do need fairly expert
here but um but the other half a newbie
Rosalie transients and social images
first they still have a right to access
health because it seems can go long
currently in Australia and going back to
two thousand late at least at least
thirty incentive young name of a
diagnosable mental disorder thirty-one
percent of young women forever access
any title for question of the world care
and the Royal evidence-based care so
very minimal levels access to viewership
head and we have not built this the
little spell of our consistent for young
people that is a completely missing
element from probably lean adolescents
in particular 220s when there's a great
way for it especially general
information intensive care and various
divisions thermometer care where I tour
the younger kids and delays adults with
chronic illnesses and anybody else pays
really sound we have embarked on Alameda
with all causes Australia news web see
which were collected over the last ten
years and this is described in detail in
a paper Lance of psychiatry and 2014 to
say the 2014 and it's so something has
to be happening other countries to this
partnership will ask some remaining
people with so far has been head space
which is a inherent primary care service
for young people aged 12 to 25 which
focuses on medical alcohol level drugs
because you
vocational existence and I suppose can
we support youth participation or other
key ingredients as well all in a
one-stop shop so youth cafes and
environment youth friendly care
practitioners help staff youth workers
vocational program and maybe a business
special psychiatry in course we're
possible to enhance primary care but
still quite specialized but the front
line you can log in you can reup you can
access it online tui headspace and it's
transformed access from the 15 on the
left quanti old-fashioned good at
keeping people out to system on the
right that's engaging attractive got
some key components are essential the
one-stop shop out here with the I
authority to solar fire and the
atmosphere baby section that people
clean for their iPhones relationship I
have with them that's what we want to
try and craving are never work
environments our culture's care
welcoming the kg and Riza failing it
would be a hundred of the examples
around strata this year probably money
for an operation that's about fifty
percent of population coverage so we're
halfway there with our primary care
model and advertise going to give today
but we are a number of papers published
but large data sets from Congress this
reform and sort of problem is places
presentable they're not required to take
up all the boxes i'll add sm school
schedule or manual page they be
presenting problems yeah it might be
bling or effectively legs I strength
exam stress relationship problems and so
on and often these things sweated
manifestation of something deeper going
on and all their quarters and their
concomitant of these what we call a
little disorders and they're often
physical issues to be TT
horrible drugs are self medication for
economy and particularly practical
problems with educational pathways and
with vocational at work and end with
family relationships mostly families are
very important to be supporting ignore
me right up to the edge of a tired look
at stopping a veena so often happens to
very perfect stage administer we are
happy into early stages in the census we
were hoping and since a research
platform to come back to a minute the
outcomes are better in terms of distress
and functioning even a short period of
time and we do in a backup special
system to support this but there is
something that's much more difficult to
construct and resource rare and later as
much baggage with that so then you're
not much more ever since of expertise
and back in this and frontline sort of
service you thought help is a key reform
upfront and it's going to be a huge
infrastructure for learning about happy
things will develop and have true
contender developing and testing your
treatments but as some of social
movements you've evolved young people
very strongly in this reserved a special
youth Mental Health Association young
people together with ourselves and with
this business or Declaration and you get
all the key targets that suicide and
employment and our weather on a
practical outcomes in well we've had
strange metal concerts or huge successes
with soon as the audience be and people
themselves so 200 round six hundred and
what we all know young people agreed
without mechanisms and and researchers
and clinicians and policymakers and so
on all coming together and we go to
learn a lot more and they going to do NT
transforming and biological research
cyber social circuit in London obsessed
they're all key contributors and pillars
to actually make this actually work on a
scientific and it is based platform so
these are powerful ideas there are deals
okay whose time has come and this is the
yeah Felger the Royal Flying Doctor
Service Australia Junction e it's still
going strong after a really hundred
years and he said apiece travel idea
nothing would stop it well let's lock
that's very true because this has to be
stage-managed and we'd never be
translated into reality and lots of good
ideas that haven't been so the whole
series of steps the innovation cycle
it's probably good way of figured out
and it's my actually rocket science of
the anything in this life straight say
this is because a lot of us just common
sense the rocket science comes in the
research side where the context into the
brain the complexity of human might have
to be studied normal students in ways
that will help us to deliver our mission
but the essential being the mission is
something that I can share if you like
to anyone that as a human being is Dean
Young and complete this period of
devices struggled and family members a
particularly worried about their teenage
your young adult kids and the society as
a whole it can become the economic and
productivity aspects of society very
dependent on on all of these young
people as many as possibly reaching
their potential and running the other
locations or the atomic scrappy and so
these are major functional as well and
economic issues as well as and
psychological biological and our hope
and 20 transforming peer into the future
we will be able to play our role but we
do need frameworks and paradigms changes
work with meaning let's not try to share
some of the thinking that we've had
about those issues with you today so in
closing of the truck to acknowledge and
warm iron maybe colleagues in the
Australia we worked for a long period
together traveling around basically in
the people and top out of the slime of
course people in many other countries as
well usually early psychosis but Lloyd
one leads me and use a little help from
an intervention never filled and only
fun
the support was your sage as well at
least I'll get you listed basis so thank
you very much for watching today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through September 2016 you'll
receive an email from lab roots alerting
you in this webcast to be available for
replay we invite you to forward that
announcements your colleagues you may
have missed today's live event see you
next time goodbye
you
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through September 2016
you'll receive an email from lab brutes
alerting you when this webcast will be
available for replay we invite you to
forward that announcement to your
colleagues you may have missed today's
live event see you next time goodbye
you